Hắn sau năm 2018, nền nghiệp cao thi lục tại nhiều khu vực chính thị giới,
sắc lập của bất mởi trong cuộc khu hủng hạn khi hậu toàn cầu.
Thều dựa ở tư duy trình có phê niết khách của AIU,
ý nhất 122 của thắn sau năm nhất lịch sử, trong khi 2,5 sống nước khác sẽ thứ 2,
khoảng 20,5 trăm chỉ mấy trưởng người tại 3 chú lục,
phải sống trong điều kiện thử tiếp các nghiệp khi nền nghiệp nhiều nơi vật xa chuẩn trù mình lịch sử.
Tại trở ổ, nhiều khu vực không quan về nền nảo như bỉ, hay hả ngăn,
với nhận mức nghiệp cao bất hưởng pháp anh và nhiều nước khác,
cũng với nhận thẳng 6,5 trông lịch sử.
Tại trù á, nhật bản hành của với Trung Quốc,
đồng loạt lập kỳ lục mới,
bế độ kiều khiến thời diệm nóng nhất 6 tiếng sống,
kéo dài và chỉ bếng cửa n hơn,
như độ mặt biển tăng, tây trồng và mù vụ bị đạo lộn.
Châu Phi cũng không nằm ngoài xu rướng,
liên trị rùa, nằm xu đăng và nhiều cuối ra chung đông Phi,
với nhận mức nghiệp khách nghiệp trước tưởng thấy
làm chương trồng thêm tình trảm ất độ đón nhèo và suy sạm chứ lượng sống.
Chúng tôi kể nè những tình báo của dưới khoa không còn là dự báo xa sôi,
mà đăng hiện dệm nè Trung Quốc sống hàng ngày,
mối thẳng nắng nắm cửa nguang qua đi, là một lời nhất nhật.
Bình độ kiểu không còn lần quý cơ tương ai mà là thực tải không thể chữ bảo.